yeah and we saw a movie last week though
that was pretty [ __ ] scary pretty
good you guys don't breathe don't
breathe
it's about decisions why people make
that it cost them their lives and it's
like decision making that you know that
only they can make you can't put African
Americans in a movie like that and just
don't look at George's face look at his
face look at his face okay guys you can
see this face don't ever look at me like
that when I talk about why people
because I'll tell you why
okay well when ethnic people they kill
people they kill them when you guys do
it you make curtains and also eat them
that's torture you don't mean like
Dahmer or Ed Gein yeah you made
lampshade out of human skin you guys
always take it to the next level
Hitler that's another level look at me
right now doing so when I say stuff like
you know why people make decisions that
are a little different don't look with
your like confused eyes like you're
being you're being racist or you know
I'm not I'm looking at factual things
like movies like movies and real-life
experiences Hitler Hitler yeah so I mean
you don't make decisions like that or
that's completely different from what
I'm saying because that's a religious
zealot right and it's I'm talking about
America in America and in a free society
okay where you have a melting pot a
melting pot of all kinds of races and
you why people just do weirder edgier
things and decision this decision making
Japanese went crazy on Korea and the
Philippines yeah
I mean burglars of Asia yeah but that's
we're now talking about no no we're
talking about like dictators and the
movie no no I'm not gonna go back to the
movie yet because I'm tired of his
George's [ __ ] facial expressions it's
like last week when his guy Gary Johnson
I don't know what Aleppo was I explain
to everybody who Gary Johnston Gary
Johnson is a libertarian candidate right
that's the third party there's actually
four parties right just fine oh yeah
there's a green party all right
yeah and so Gary Johnson his boy gets on
Morning Joe on NBC MSNBC and one of the
commentators or whatever said on what
are you gonna do Aleppo and his boy goes
what's a limo and the guy goes you got
to be [ __ ] kidding me
he didn't say [ __ ] but but that's
what he meant to say yeah and he goes no
I'm serious what is Aleppo and Aleppo is
a city in Syria where it's the melting
pot broke but joe scarborough's like
well it's basically the central hub of
the syrian refugee crisis and this he's
telling the guy who's like a
presidential candidate this well that's
disqualifying and George was like well
what if he was thinking and George
completely defended him we try to defend
him and I don't want him as
commander-in-chief because I'm a full
blown [ __ ] so be quiet everyone in the
room just shut the [ __ ] up I am gonna
own up to what I am okay I am not smart
I'm not healthy I make really awful life
decisions health decisions I don't you
know what I'm alive I never had any kind
of education I went to six months of
junior college and I just kind of just
never went really and I've never really
read a book I know what Aleppo is and
I'm not running for the President of the
United States
it's disqualifying and look at me in the
eyes and say it to everyone right now I
need you to say it Gary Johnson is he's
not gonna make a good president he's
disqualified he's disqualified come here
for a second
yes no facial expressions [ __ ] say it
too
Carrie Johnson would in the war on drugs
which is the biggest problem that we've
seen in politics recently 80% of the
problems with drugs and everybody claims
the problems with drugs are the problem
with the war on drugs it's destroyed the
inner city it's destroyed Mexico it's
destroyed Colombia and if we had Gary
Johnson as president we would thank you
for participating thank you thank you so
much for that thank you um that's what
I'm talk--i is ridiculous right now yeah
that's another white thing yeah let's
not take it's a point of view that it's
almost impossible to defend but they'll
just go out and just defend it full
force you know is that a white thing no
because what he's actually saying is
making sense to me it's actually
resonating with me because it's like but
is a white people thing to do it's like
you know you're wrong but somehow you're
still gonna sit there and defend it to
your death like Ann Coulter is that a
white thing or is that is that just the
your [ __ ] confused face right now
anyway Gary Johnson should know what a
la Poe is and I don't know if the truth
be told he's better qualified than
Donald Trump
but let me tell you something in this
election it looks more and more like he
could win Donald Trump
[Music]